[Music]
one spring break vacation when christian
and i were kids our father announced
that we were going to canada
it was a very small motel that we stayed
at in um hull quebec he was very on the
border not a place that most people come
for vacation unless it wasn't a
five-star hotel it was not and in fact
it was very it just was small and we
were all staying in the same room and i
threw a little bit of a tantrum that
might be the biggest understatement
i've ever heard in my opinion this is
embarrassing because also on the way up
the whole time he was like
our dad he was building it up in your
defense our father was like there's
gonna be a like a heated pool yeah a spa
and a sauna and all this stuff and you
were getting more and more excited and
then he finally pulled into this place
and
you thought he was joking he was like
you were like very funny you're just
turning around he's like nope we're here
i couldn't believe it you got so mad you
threw yourself
out of the car onto the ground and you
were beside yourself really i still
remember it and then you had a book of
matches i remember and you were flicking
them in anger you were lighting oh my
goodness
i've never seen a meltdown well that
makes it sound like we were used to like
anyway here's here's the show oh god
it's okay life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your currently embarrassed host justin
long life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my more prudent
but although you would throw tantrums
too no i didn't oh god i was excited to
stay in this place i need to clarify a
few things this makes it sound like we
were rich kids growing up
that i'm used to like we never stayed in
hotels that were uh i don't think you
have to explain this i i said that it
was
like over hyped it was oversold to you
my dad was [ __ ] an affluenza kid he
was messing with you yeah he was
building it up that was mean of him he
tried i i don't know i don't really know
why he did that he was being a rascal
pop could be a like mischief maker yeah
he liked it he was being arrested like
he was getting you really excited about
this place and the place itself was fine
it was fine it just wasn't
nearly what he was describing so your
tantrum
was i would say somewhat justified and
it was also not your typical reaction i
was a kid you were a kid you were what
17 18. shut up here's the point though
you ended up having a good time on the
trip i did yes or no i did and and more
importantly that
was the trip where you started to fall
in love with canada if you listen to the
show it's no secret that i do and you're
right i love canada as do i don't bother
i love everything about it i love the
people you love butchering their accents
oh i sure do eh
i sure do i'm so sorry about that if
about that if you're from canada um but
i also love you guys so i i it's with
affection that i do the accent and uh so
today i'm very excited why are we
speaking about canada the drum roll
please
is i would say
the most canadian guest we've had oh
yeah yeah one of them uh kobe
yeah but he's more canadian i think i
would say she
doesn't seem as confused
when i think canada i think our guest
well you know why because kobe is an
actress and has to had her her accent's
been more diluted over the years
whereas why a a and whereas toms you
know
hasn't as much so our guest today he's
got that is the great yeah
tom green yeah yo yeah yeah he's got
that very canadian cadence right kind of
goes up at the end yeah and christian
and i were we were such big fans of tom
green that uh
there's a very embarrassing video out
there of me
and my friend jeff ostriker shout out
going across the country we were we
drove across the country and we we
wanted to be like tom green we filmed
ourselves kind of messing with people
and i say it's embarrassing because
we kind of had a shitty attitude with
people and some people didn't want to be
filmed yeah it's just not but you
aspired to be like tom green we thought
he was so funny and and there was
something so we talked about this but
there was something so dangerous about
what he did wasn't there punk rock punk
rock yeah he was punk rock yeah he sure
was and um and when it comes to
podcasting he's one of the originals tom
has really paved the way for a lot of uh
pop culture tom green
became famous in the 90s on the time
green show on mtv
and we were at the age where we just
completely fell in love with that
type of humor and
uh you guys talk a bit about where that
comes from in him and how that developed
in him yeah i was really curious to talk
to him i had been on a show he was guest
hosting for larry king a few months
earlier i guess this is last summer when
we were promoting this podcast and uh he
was very
so nice to me he was so like very almost
deferential and
really seemed to
like me i don't know i so which i liked
him selfishly i was like well that's i
like that he likes me
um and uh we talked about at that time
him doing the podcast so i'm glad it got
to happen and i'm glad we got to have
him on it was a thrill to talk to him
so let's get into it uh you'll hear our
excitement my excitement uh when i talk
to
i would say the legend hmm don't you
will not dispute that all right so here
we go my talk eh
god i'm so sorry canadian listeners this
is gonna be brutal for him but it's all
out of love it's all out of love
uh as is my conversation with
the legendary tom green
life could be a dream
hello hello against your booming over
we'll meet
[Music]
here we go yeah all right we are all
systems go now that we're quarantined
you find yourself doing more face times
than you normally do i find myself
talking to more people than i usually do
oh yeah i've been facetiming all my
friends and uh
family and a lot of face time i have a
little i have a little tripod that i
have my phone on pretty much i leave it
on this tripod it's one it's one of
those ones with the little bendy legs
you know it's got a little yeah
you can like wrap the legs around stuff
and so it sort of like hangs on things
and yeah i have it with me all the time
and then sometimes i'll i'll go on my
instagram story do you do that go live
in your instagram story i've been
watching them and i find that can i'm
always paranoid that people are going to
see me leaving the instagram live can
you see when people leave or you just
see when they're there oh yeah yeah you
can it's a little bit of a privacy
infringement on the viewer yeah which is
funny because yeah i've had people pop
on and then get mad that i didn't say hi
to them because i did i just didn't
notice they were there um oh but it's
kind of fun it's kind of fun when you're
streaming live because you see your
friends pop up and then and then you
sort of start talking to them and it's
uh it's kind of cool i'm in a weird
situation right now justin i don't i
don't get too deep into my situation i'm
in a weird situation my house by myself
so it's kind of hilarious yeah but weird
you know yeah well so um are you
climbing the walls you have you have
this very elaborate setup so you're able
to broadcast your you have to your own
studio there really which i want to get
into that too because you were ahead of
the curve with all of that i've just
heard you talking to joe rogan about it
is it keeping you distracted and and
feeling like connected
yeah for sure so basically i uh i
started my podcast again my actual audio
podcast like a month ago i've been doing
it every day wow and it's keeping me
busy every day yeah i mean i take a day
off here and there but it's really it's
a it's not a long pod i do sometimes
it's only 20 minutes long okay sometimes
it's sometimes it's in an hour depending
who i'm talking to like like i talked to
a ufo uh an alien abduction expert two
days ago who was the predominant expert
in alien abduction in the world he's
traveled around the world he's removed
uh objects that have been you know
implanted into people's bodies it's
quite serious do you believe in that
stuff what was it like being on the
other end of that i believe in a lot of
that stuff i mean i definitely believe
in the possibility that there is
intelligent life in the universe rather
than ours or maybe even uh you know
there is the only intelligent life in
the universe might be on another planet
who knows but uh right but i definitely
do believe in that do i believe they're
visiting i'm not sure i've seen no
evidence of that but i also believe but
did he present evidence this guy yeah oh
very much so so he definitely is very
much uh in in full belief first of all
his name's derek sims he's uh
alienhunter.org is his website
alienhunter.org and he uh was abducted
as a as a child uh told me about that
and then his son was also abducted and
uh he is he was an ex-cia agent as he
told me he was did any of this check out
for example that well i don't really do
a lot of research on my show i just kind
of took his word for it right
that's what it said on this website
though but i mean i believe him oh okay
all right well if it was on the internet
sure so but i believe him i believe him
what he seemed very credible i mean he
definitely was very very uh uh versed in
all of this so yeah tom where do you
find somebody like that how how did you
get in touch with somebody like that you
know we all go down these rabbit holes
on the internet where i don't know if
i'm sure you do i do yeah yeah if you're
a curious person you go on the internet
you start you start exploring and
looking at conspiracy theories and of
course i just actually i also just
interviewed one of the uh uh russell
accord one of the most uh world's most
predominant bigfoot sasquatch
researchers as well so that was pretty
cool that was pretty fun
and uh so it's cool it's not all that
kind of stuff on my show though i've had
a lot of uh you know comedians i'd love
to have you call in sometimes i'd love
that's how you've been doing it yeah
it's just audio right now but i'm going
to put cameras on it i've had you know
chris angel called in dane cook called
it jeff ross called in last week
comedians and people so that's funny you
mentioned yeah but you had had a podcast
earlier right so you had stopped doing
it for a while yeah so i used to do this
web streaming show in my house which was
not really officially a podcast because
i don't think it was it was sort of
early 2000s and i don't think real
podcasting was really a thing yet but it
was with cameras and we were streaming
through the internet and it was
essentially a podcast i was having up a
lot of people on the show and i was
actually so because i'm i'm here
quarantining right now i kind of was
going down memory lane going through
some hard drives and i found this great
clip of joe rogan on the show back in
2007
and uh i posted a clip of him
essentially saying this is great tom but
we got to figure out how to make money
off of this you know and then and then
here we are he's got the biggest podcast
in the world and and he saw that and
reposted it and had me on yesterday so
you sort of paved the way for a lot of
this podcasting and internet talk shows
even after you did the tom green show
jackass started right after that so you
it seems like you've been
you've had your finger on the pulse of
uh of this type of entertainment
what do you think is next where do you
think things are headed because uh
you're very prophetic when it comes to
this i've always been into technology i
don't know why i think my friends were
really into computers and stuff when i
was growing up because in i'm from
ottawa and uh i know you've been to hull
we can talk about that in a bit but yeah
i've been uh wait yeah yeah
but uh so you know a lot of my friends
were in computer engineering and my
father actually when he left the
military began uh working in computer
engineering so we kind of had some early
sort of influences in that and so i
always liked looking at technology and
then i studied broadcasting in school
and started playing with video cameras
so now i don't know it's interesting
it's probably got something to do with
artificial intelligence
i would say maybe some sort of virtual
reality some sort of virtual world maybe
will actually be inside the talk show
living inside the talk show i personally
love interactivity i love interactivity
so i love
having lots of different types of
interactivity on the show so people
calling in people you know
you know interacting with the show live
that that could be where it's going
yeah you would do that with man on the
street type stuff too you were uh joe
joe touches on this in the podcast that
you should all listen to
um that we are
communicating in such an odd way now
this was he was talking about this in
the context of um instagram comments and
responding to comments and stuff like
that
it's just not a natural way to
communicate and
how do you manage that um communicating
with people on the internet not not
letting it get the best of you okay so
i've got like sort of a controversial
way of handling this okay i'm gonna dip
into some controversy right now okay
okay so cause some people say okay this
is a democratic thing you should be able
to let people say whatever they want and
yeah yeah people should be able to go on
your feet and you know call you an
[ __ ] or you know say mean things or
or be haters or trolls or whatever you
want to call it but i've always found
and i've sort of figured this out more
and more over the years that if you
allow that to fester on there if you
first of all
i never respond to negative people i
never responded that was my initial
thing i used to start started doing that
a few years ago so i just wouldn't
respond to the negative people but now
what i do is i just immediately block
them
i immediately just
and and the blocking functions are kind
of new they've become a much better than
they were 10 years ago and it's really
changed
things for the better i just block them
immediately and i will block people for
you know
sometimes it's like right on the line
like i'm not even sure if it's a
negative comment but it just kind of
yeah it just kind of made me feel a
little strange so i'll just block yeah
yeah
but if yeah i guess you're right if you
have the ability to curate your own
positive environment why not do that
it's just the way i've been doing it
we're not politicians right we don't
really have to we don't have no any
responsibility that's in the world right
that's true we can just
it doesn't have to be a democracy i
compare it almost more to real life i
remember i used to allow negativity into
my life just in general i would have
friends that would be negative and you'd
be why is that person always negative
but i would let them be in my life and i
learned as i got older no you don't need
to have any negative energy in your life
you can sort of edit that out if
somebody's cool with you you'll continue
but if someone's a prick you know just
you know block them in real in the real
world you know so so that's kind of the
way i look at it
that's true and tom
speaking of real life i mean some of the
things that people say on the internet
they would never it just that kind of
communication doesn't exist in
in real life because there's decorum
there's that there's social etiquette
there are there are certain rules that
people have to follow like you wouldn't
walk up to a stranger and say oh i think
your movie sucks or
you know you're ugly it just
had a few people that felt the need to
actually walk right up to me and tell me
yeah but uh usually on the internet but
sometimes in person yeah well well tom i
have i have i think the ver the version
of that i have is um a movie called tusk
people will come up to me oh yeah that's
an amazing movie i love that movie
yeah but see if people either love it or
hate it and the people that hate it i
always find that there's still
maybe this is just wishful thinking but
there always feels like a degree of
affection even when they're saying
that movie is [ __ ] up or what the [ __ ]
what were you thinking when you did that
um i i wonder if if freddie got fingered
is it's the same kind of misplaced
affection because i do know that movie
has become like a cult classic and
way ahead of its time that uh and we've
talked a little bit about it i think um
but it's it's amazing that they
let you take the chances that you took
in that movie that's that's certain it's
funny how when you decide to make a
choice and make something extremely
polarizing and you go into it knowing
that it's going to be extremely
polarizing but
in my mind i always thought oh this is
so polarizing that people are going to
realize that it's supposed to be
polarizing and then everybody's going to
love it you know no no no it's actually
polarizing
that's right
yeah so which is fine so then you just
kind of you just kind of go oh okay it
worked that's what was supposed to be
polarizing okay
yeah well i mean i didn't mean that
polarizing i thought it was going to
flip over and become you know
not yeah polarizing to a degree yeah
yeah
but did the studio did they fight you on
because that was a major that was fox i
think right or yeah new regions see fox
new regions listen they were really cool
with me i you know they were really cool
uh they let me they let me make that
movie and
uh they let me direct it i was not even
directing it originally and it was
really it was really cool who was
supposed to direct it uh there was no
one really supposed to direct it i wrote
it i wrote the movie with my friend and
then we we had initially we started
talking about other directors and then i
just kind of said i you know i i really
want to make this really like this
really weird you know and i really want
to push the envelope with some of the
scenes where to me it was more about the
not so much about directing the actors
because honestly i don't know a lot
about acting you know like i was doing
my goofy show i'm not really well an
actor but i like it i like i like wanted
to make i want to make the scenes crazy
looking you know like i wanted the
sausages to hang from the ceiling just
right you know i wanted i wanted the
cheese to drip just the right way it was
supposed to drip you know so oh
interesting
but you're working with some really
incredible actors so what
how did you approach that like riptorn
for example who
rest in peace rip yeah
but he's a legend i mean what was it
like uh i know you work with him too in
dodgeball right so yeah yeah yeah yeah
rip play patches or houlihan in
dodgeball um yeah he he was a tough
cookie
yeah
which was cool because you know his
character was a tough cookie too he was
playing exactly
i really enjoyed directing actually and
working with him and julie hagerty and
uh yeah
all the people
because it was kind of interesting
because
i don't know i just i just i enjoy
working with people and talking to
people and and rip had a good time rip
told me he enjoyed uh enjoyed that uh
process oh really
he would go out in the weekend he would
go on the weekend we were in vancouver
shooting it and uh he would go on the
weekend and like catch salmon and go
fishing and then you come in he'd bring
like giant salmon and we'd be eating
fresh salmon in the
lunch you know so he was he was cool man
he was cool
tough cookie though i mean there were
times where
i you know i was like okay you're
actually really really mad at me right
now this is not about uh this is not
about you know when things were taken
too long or whatever you know but that's
cool you know he was an older guy at
that point so so you kind of wanted to
respect the fact that you wanted to
get them through it you know did you
feel some sort of
pressure to
because you had such a clear persona and
you were so beloved by
the younger generation did you feel
pressure to maintain that level of
edginess and extreme comedy
in the movies in those movies it just
depends certainly that was what i was
trying to continue with freddie got
fingered there were some movies that i
really did get into the idea of trying
to immerse myself into you know a
comedic character like i did this movie
stealing harvard with jason lee and yeah
i got like
false teeth put in and i you know really
kind of grew my hair out i kind of
adopted a little bit of a of a of a
character and an accent and things like
that so that was really cool i did feel
that a lot more
outside of the work like if i were to go
on
the tonight show i felt like oh i can't
just go on and just talk about what i'm
doing i got to go in there and do
something insane
so there's a lot of things where i kind
of look back and i think to myself
i should have probably just chilled a
little bit you
sort of youthful kind of desire to just
sort of be so completely insane all the
time it did definitely confuse a lot of
people which was to me funny at the time
but now i'm a little older i look back
at it i go maybe i could have sometimes
gone on and just kind of been normal you
know been more who i really am i'm kind
of
semi-normal in my real life you know
yeah and and i'm not normal at all when
i was doing that stuff so right but at
the time but how much of that was just
youthful like exuberance and how much of
it was you
pushing the envelope or deliberately
uh leaning into a persona or a character
i wonder oh yeah no it's definitely that
my friends and i were trying to [ __ ] up
the system you know we really had this
sort of desire to really go
you know be
nuts and i think sometimes it might push
people in the wrong way because it was
like you know it was always on or
whatever but now i've kind of realized i
did stand up when i was a kid but i
wasn't really doing like when i was a
teenager in early 20s but i wasn't
really doing stand-up for a few years
when i was on mtv and i started doing
that again that's really what i do
full-time until until now i have my
whole years was just canceled and as
well which i'm you know which is
everybody's out of work right now so
it's it's a it's a tough thing for the
country and for everybody but yeah but
uh you know i i have this outlet now
where i can get up on stage now and be
you know
you know a whack a wacko you know a
goofball and just kind of completely
have that energy
and then when i do my podcast or when i
talk to you
i can just you know give you an honest
answer and you know have fun with it but
not necessarily be trying to confuse
everybody all the time you know yeah i
think a lot of people also i mean i
remember seeing that side of you and
being surprised by it when uh you got
cancer and and you made the decision to
talk about it publicly i that was like a
such an extreme pivot because i was such
a fan of yours of your comedy but i had
never seen you
be earnest and or not earnest serious i
guess and was shifting into a serious
mode
challenging was it scary i i i think a
lot most people had only seen you known
you to be funny what was that like uh
well first of all it was very strange
for sure um you know i had been working
away in my little show up in canada for
years as a public access show right and
we worked hard on it my friends and i we
all work for years for many many years
almost almost 10 years so when i got the
cancer
it was real shitty you know it's shitty
getting cancer you know it's not it's
not a it's not a fun thing to get cancer
but it's even worse when you've been
working towards getting your show on the
air for 10 years right
on the air and everything's going great
we had just moved from new york to los
angeles and all the
a lot of the crew on the show producers
camera people you know the show was
doing great we had a hit show so it was
we were like okay we're moving to la
we're going to be doing this for years
people gave up apartments you know
people left new york to come out to l.a
wow and then i got to la and in
six months within six months i got the
the testicular cancer i got it and uh
thank you i thought okay we'll do one
last show it'll give everyone another
couple of months of work all the editors
and stuff also you know we realized this
will be a good way to you know talk
about balls on television and it'll be
kind of fun yeah we can get away get
away with talking about balls on
television
and and last but not least maybe would
even help some people too so yeah we did
it we just filmed everything
wow we were apprehensive about that was
that it was that a difficult decision to
make because that seems like such a
revealing thing it's it's one thing to
be funny around people and
mess with people and stuff but
when it comes to something that personal
um what was that like coming up that to
wrestling with that decision
yeah it was not an instant decision
because i did think and i don't think
that now but at the time i thought geez
this could be really embarrassing you
know like they're taking my right
testicle
everyone's gonna know that i only have
one testicle i mean that's that's
embarrassing
we were always trying to think of this
the craziest thing to do even for years
up to that point whether it was you know
paint your parents car or whatever weird
thing we would do on the show
so now it was kind of like this is the
craziest thing ever we have to film this
and then what took over also is that uh
you know
it is the most prevalent form of cancer
in young guys 15 to 35 years old so
everyone watching my show was 15 to 35
years old and so we we raised a lot of
awareness for it and i tell you man it's
it's when i tour around the country
not
it's often not a month goes by now used
to be even more frequent but not a month
goes by now where if some
man will walk up to me
with his wife and they'll be
very emotional and they'll say you know
when i was
30 years old i uh i went to get to the
doctor because of that show you know and
so it's that's happened countless times
i've had lots of letters and things so
it's cool and anyone listening you know
if you're feeling any sort of discomfort
not just in your
testicle but anywhere in your body i
just say go to the doctor right away
because like if you don't get stuff
early that's when you kind of are in
trouble but it's highly curable if you
go right away so were you at all
religious at the time tom were you
thinking about the afterlife did you
ever go there like that extreme uh yeah
i actually did i actually did have a
moment
really getting into it here justin
you're gonna make me cry like barbara
walters does to her guests well
this is always our goal yeah yeah even
if they're fake tears thank you you know
there was there was a moment for sure
where i was so
upset about it and this was early on in
the process of realizing this uh i was
actually in the shower and i remember
sitting there and i remember like with
the hot water pouring down over my
face and i just remember thinking
thinking and praying to god like for
real like actually praying to god and
yeah you know i've you know i grew up
you know we went to church when we were
a kid when i was a kid we went to sunday
school but we were not like overly
religious family but you know we had
sunday school yeah catholic times
protestant one side's presbyterian
anglican i was i forget which one i am
that's how that's how religious i am but
here it was a moment where i was
genuinely without any sense of irony of
of course you know uh praying to god
saying geez i just would like to get
through this and live and you know and
then look i lived and i'm still here
talking to you so i do actually
allow that to uh be something that i
think about sometimes that you know it
worked you know it did work i did pray
to god to live and survive that ordeal
and and things have been been good and
i'm and so i i don't uh discount life
could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
your parents at the time i remember
thinking too when because they were on
the special
the cancer special and i remember
thinking god these people
have been you put them through such they
had such patience but you really tested
their patients and i remember thinking
there's a real sweetness and affection
that these people have for one another i
was really struck by that i have a very
close relationship with my parents and
it's kind of funny because
people
really often misconstrue
some of those bits uh and they say man
matt you you were so mean to your
parents but they don't quite understand
that i mean i know some of it was a
little over the top but but you know we
always had this sort of joking
relationship like you know
my parents are very funny at the dinner
table you know when you're funny people
kind of around each other always razzing
each other and it kind of evolved slowly
too like i would they were happy that i
was doing something like i was i was in
school taking broadcasting i was trying
to do something with my life so
and the other thing is the videos were
really spread out further my parents
disagree with this no when i talk about
i say oh we only went did i say we only
did something every once every couple of
months and they said no it was every
wednesday [ __ ] night you'd barge in
and you know but uh yeah but it was
further apart than it appeared on mtv
where we were hammering them every
episode because you know it was sort of
four or five years worth of stuff all
clump clumped into like you know a
couple of months so but they also seemed
like they had very dry strikes was very
canadian their sense of humor oh tom
sure it's they
seemed funny but very dry and very dry
so maybe people were con
misconstrued that as well um for being
annoyed or upset uh i'm sure i did in
terms of doing bits like that with your
parents i know i know you had mentioned
that when you painted their car more
than painted their car i mean you
it was called the slot mobile yeah right
i think yeah it was it was a nice
painting
yes it was like a ridiculously graphic
sexual painting on the side of their car
and i think it was your father who
refused to take the car he started
walking
yeah um that bit struck me as like okay
now he's in trouble they're genuinely
upset
how long would their anger last like
with something like that for example how
how long did it take for them to
laugh about it let's see you know and i
don't even know if it's pc anymore to
say the [ __ ] mobile i think we could get
away with that in 1999 but i don't even
know if you could say that anymore so
yeah
i'm i'm at least acknowledging that but
uh yes um and apologizing for that i
guess for that yeah just saying the word
it's not being insensitive but that's
what it was called um
you know the thing is there's a secret
to
that video that did not get seen on
camera which is kind of a fun little i
think piece of magic that makes it a
little less mean than it appeared
because
what we did was this was one of our
first bits where we actually had a
little bit of a budget
my parents had a 1992 honda accord so we
went we bought an extra hood you know an
extra hood to a 1992 honda accord
because we realized it was going to take
too long for the paint to dry because
it's that beautiful 1970s van air
brushing art you know like very hyper
realistic beautiful paint art you know
it looks very beautiful the ladies on
the car look very beautiful
yes they were right and so
we had it sent off to this guy uh just
up north of ottawa in this little town
called greely who uh he was he paints
vans
and probably like work had dried up a
little bit because people weren't really
painting you know airbrushing their vans
as much anymore in the early 90s so he's
probably happy for the work at the time
you know
yeah yeah yeah so we we had him do it
and it was so we we bought the the the
paint job was was like 200 bucks and the
hood itself was 250 bucks
we painted it we had it all done and
then in the middle of the night we just
swapped out the hoods oh
wow
and then dad got mad and then mom got
mad and then mom left all these
answering machine messages on my on my
answering machine right because we had
answering machines back then
and and then we and then they they got
mad and we filmed them until they were
kind of like
until it wasn't funny anymore basically
which was right well it's kind of a long
time actually like it was not like we
didn't we didn't reveal like within 10
minutes oh we're just joking bring the
other yeah it was like a good like eight
eight or 12 hours of of getting yelled
at oh my god and then when we realized
that we had enough footage and it
probably was just not funny anymore we
brought the hood out did they ever
within those eight like on hours seven
or eight did they ever say oh tom put
the camera down where did they ever go
after the camera oh yeah oh yeah
and my mom was really worried because
her
her her mother and her sister
were coming to visit uh that day from
another city and they were driving and
it was there was a ticking clock of
tension because they were gonna be there
soon it was a six hour drive and they
were getting closer
your grandmother and she i imagine she's
a very sweet gentleman very sweet
canadian woman yeah she was very sweet
yes
okay so but we didn't show that aspect
on it we just kind of we just kind of
didn't show that part which which you
know debatably would have been funny to
show the end you know like on all candid
camera shows they always showed at the
end no it's okay look they're all behind
the curtain it's okay you know we didn't
do well
you know i wonder that about i've been
so into the show on practical jokers
since uh oh yeah
i just i just discovered it um which is
nice because i've years it's been on for
like eight years oh wow yeah you'll have
you'll be able to fill your whole
quarantine with that show they've been
there like season 200 right now or
something i know it's been keeping me so
entertained but um i always wish that
they would then show a little bit more
behind the curtain uh they do sometimes
but um
i always i'm curious how the people
respond once they realize it's a hidden
camera camera show uh
and and
yeah i'm always curious about that
aspect of it like oh wow yeah how do
they wrap it i think we never hit our
camera that well rarely a couple of
times we did but to us it was like the
camera was a character in the show right
it was kind of like
who's this kid with a camera sticking a
camera in my [ __ ] space and it would
make people even madder you know the
first bit that we shot when we went to
new york was called undercutters pizza
and i was you got chased me with a
hammer in line on long island and tried
to break our camera so that's right he'd
ruined your pizza right didn't he uh
well he had ordered he we staked out the
pizza the pizza joint
i was dressed as a pizza guy
high falutin stuff here you know like i
i i it's it's lofty material i followed
the pizza guy and then we got to the
place where he was delivering the pizza
i walked up with the pizza guy who
didn't know why i was following him i
had a plain pizza and a fishing tackle
box because a fishing tackle box is a
perfect thing to put pizza condiments in
because it's all divided into those
little sections for the cheese and the
mushrooms yeah
right and then i tried to make the guy a
pizza for and then sell it for cheaper
undercutters undercutting and he got mad
but the thing is it was supposed to be
the pizza guy was supposed to get mad
but the guy delivered it to actually got
mad this new york accented long island
accent guy he was working on his car and
he came at me with a hammer and it was
fun that's right
that must have been terrifying i mean
things like that did that was that scary
the only reason it got a little scary
was because it was the first time i'd
worked with this camera guy because he
was the mtv camera guy and i tried to
explain to him like if someone starts
chasing us like we've got to back off
and he didn't understand the rhythm of
that he just sort of held his ground and
wanted to keep filming and i don't think
he quite realized that the guy was
actually going to hit him with right
with that he wasn't a he wasn't a
willing participant in that you hear me
actually yelling in the bit matt his
name was madame
this is the light remember that this is
the line matt yeah
did you notice the difference between
people you would play pranks on dubits
with in canada versus the americans i
did yeah for sure that was when i
noticed right there at that moment yeah
yeah
americans they're they're a little more
edgy than us canadians
well canadians probably have a higher
threshold maybe a little bit more
patient
it's interesting because i mean i don't
know how far into the weeds we want to
get into this subtlety of this but it is
interesting because it did actually
change the comedy because in canada
people would sort of let it play out and
it became more of an absurd surreal kind
of interaction whereas in in the states
it became more of a angry interaction
yeah and you know it there sometimes was
actually far far more exciting actually
shooting the bits in the states but it
was a little bit more
you know you were a little bit more
ready to run basically had to run a few
times were the ones that you were like
even uh like even for me this is this is
too much and it just won't be funny
there was a bit that they wanted me to
do
my [ __ ] friends but this was
literally more of a stunt they wanted to
to mimic that bit where remember the guy
tied a bunch of balloons to a lawn chair
and then he like flew
like helium balloons
it was like a guy in like the 80s tied
like a whole bunch of weather balloons
to a lawn chair full of helium and flew
and they made a documentary about him
and i uh
he had a pellet gun and his idea was
going to shoot one balloon at a time and
then come down and at the end and all
that
they wanted me to do that and i said
i'm not doing that
did your fame ever overtake the man on
the street kind of like exposure
did the exposure ever ever get in the
way of
the comedy that's why we moved to los
angeles because new york was just too
compressed the people were just too many
people everywhere so you couldn't really
walk around with a camera without
getting kind of called out immediately
so we moved out to la and we'd drive
around in a van with tinted windows and
wait till we found somebody who looked
like they were you know
you know over 60 and then we got out and
make fun of it really
well i wonder that i mean it kind of
turned into that there's a reason why
there's a lot of elder people being
goofed on because they weren't watching
mtv so they didn't really react the same
way i remember driving cross-country
with my friend jeff we wanted to be like
you do what you were doing we filmed
everything and i recently went back and
i saved it all i i um converted it to
dvd recently and i watched some of it
and i was actually kind of at the time i
remember thinking it was we were so
funny and oh we're like tom green and
we're so edgy and i when i watched it
recently i was sort of i was kind of
ashamed
uh yeah that's kind of how i feel when i
look at my old stuff too oh really i
wonder
uh i think it's natural to look at
anything that you did over 20 years ago
and scratch your head and say what the
[ __ ] was i i thinking yeah yeah yeah do
you regret which ones i'm curious which
ones you regret well i don't really
regret any of them because i mean the
thing is is at the time we would say to
ourself okay this was the writing
process we would say okay let's try to
think of something that you're going to
regret in 20 years and then we'll go do
that
so that was usually how we came up with
our best oh that's fine it'd be kind of
disingenuous of me to like regret them
now there was always still a sense of uh
i feel we had a sort of an ethical kind
of moral compass to the show i always
did feel like if it crossed over into a
certain place then it became too mean
i sometimes see that today like
not to like you know be like the old guy
to these kids today with their pranks
you know like uh but when i i see some
of the pranksters on youtube a lot of
them are amazing
so many hilarious things on youtube now
i love it but there's occasional there's
occasional person that you see who's
takes it to a very mean place a very
dark place yeah and yeah i feel like
they're misinterpreting it and that's
their shtick but to me it's not it's not
funny at that point it's just kind of
mean and i like it when it's kind of
innocent i like i always like to feel
like if you walk out of it and you go
even though i was instigating it i was
actually the one that was kind of the
one you're worried about you know
yes exactly well like the undercutters
yeah one of the bits
that always amazed me that you would get
away with was the um the poo on the
microphone i i
i couldn't believe that um
you you could get it so cl so close to
somebody and just as a sociological
experiment that people
when they were on camera they
they didn't have as much of an aversion
to yeah
what did what do you
attribute that to
i believe people were less media
literate back then so we didn't all have
phones in with cell phones with cameras
in them we weren't all making videos we
didn't have instagram pages with videos
and facetime and all that stuff so
people when they had a camera pointed at
them in 1999
were pretty like nervous you know they
were pretty nervous they were like oh my
god i'm being i'm doing someone's asking
me to to do an interview and they're
they're yeah you know capturing my image
on a camera uh how do i look and so yeah
so but there's people weren't
literate and we've had a little we took
a little poo and we put it it was real
poo dog poo dog poop
what kind of poo was it it was poo of
the dog actually
that we uh where did you get the poo oh
well we went on the shoot and we just we
just looked around on the ground till we
found something oh my god and we spread
a little
little dollop of it on the top of our
electro voice 635a microphone right
there's probably still a mic at mtv with
poo in the grooves
who in the grooves
but anyways uh you know so but it was
fun was you know i kind of did realize
that if i made eye contact with the
people held that gaze and kind of slowly
moved the mic up close i could um i
could get it right up under their nose
and you would even see the nose
twitching a little because you could
tell they were smelling the poo it's
unmistakable under their nose
but they never they never broke
character because you know i was asking
them questions about like pete sampras
or something like that you know i was
asking questions about that tell me what
do you think of pete sampras and they're
like well he's playing pretty good right
now and he could see their nose
switching and well that's where your
acting chops came into play because
that's um that's a performance and
that's to maintain that level of
straight uh just to maintain a straight
face yeah because well because i edited
the show for years and and in the first
few years of editing the show i would
ruin so many of them by cracking up you
know i just saw rickus couldn't believe
what was happening i just started
cracking up and then it would ruin it
because then the person would realize
that i was joking with them whereas
once i learned how to not crack up you
could really string people along for a
long time without them even realizing
that you were joking because they were
sort of on nervous on camera not just
with the poo but with everything you
know like you're right right you could
say the most absurd things so yeah it
was it was crazy times fun times so you
had been doing stand-up you put it on
hold for a while uh the show happened
you have a huge career as an actor then
and then when do you return to stand up
and why do you return to stand if you
just missed it i just started feeling
like i wanted to
to do it again and uh
i started jumping up and wrote writing
some jokes and i the first night i did
it again jumped up at the comedy store
and it was you know in a open not gonna
on a you know a slow night and i just
started started doing it but i mean i
immediately immediately was fell right
back into place and i love the energy of
the crowd i love people too i love i
love being around people who
you know who who like this show and who
who like to laugh and so now i get to go
on the road and
not right now but i you know i'm on the
right last 10 years i've been on the
road i've been ever played in every city
in the u.s every city in canada i've
toured australia all over the place in
england it's it's it's exciting are
there any vestiges of like um post
cancer tom i mean did you become more
diligent about germs and getting sick
again after you had such a
oh yeah like that
oh yeah yeah well i mean absolutely
that's the reason why i legitimately
have not left the house for five weeks
other than yesterday i did leave
but yeah i mean that's i'm very very
cautious i'm very cautious about things
now because i don't because i've been
sick i think it did help me actually
prepare for this and your parents your
family's okay they're all they're all
okay yeah everyone's good and
they're all socially isolating together
with my brother and my brother's place
so so everyone's doing great your
brother's in ottawa yeah he's up in
ottawa yeah i remember going there as a
kid um my dad was a teacher he was he
taught philosophy at this college
fairfield university and
our vacations usually revolved around
one of his work trips but it was usually
not the most exciting place was it
wasn't like we were going to disney
world
you know things like that but although
we did go to disney world when i say
that and one year you went to
ottawa i went to ottawa yesterday ottawa
and we were like oh that's exciting it's
the capital of canada i was really into
geography i thought that was cool i mean
we'd see some uh and we we stayed at a
place called hull um yeah i don't know
how many of our listeners know uh what
do you think of when you think of hull
ontario okay well uh hall is actually in
quebec so we're back
so because ottawa is a you know borders
ottawa's in ontario and hull is in
quebec and it's on the border right so
it's like it sort of feels like the same
city the ottawa river splits through the
city and on one side is hull quebec and
the thing about hull which is a big deal
growing up especially back in the 80s
and
and early 90s is that um you know quebec
has a lower drinking age okay so when
you're in high school in the 80s and 14
and and the drinking age and back was 18
uh but they would still let you into the
bars when you were 16 over there so we
in high school could go over to bars in
quebec it was kind of uh we grew up fast
up there in canada yeah right to go over
the river not only that but back then
they've changed the the drinking hours
now it's evened out but back then it was
open till three in the morning in quebec
and one the bars would close at one in
the morning in ontario so it used to be
at one o'clock in the morning everybody
would drive over to hall so it was a
raging
party trip over there of nightclubs and
it was just madness back in the 80s and
90s and so we we grew up
drinking a lot and doing a lot of goofy
[ __ ] way too young over there in hull
were your parents strict about stuff
like that did you have to sneak around
tiptoe around they actually weren't
strict about stuff like that i mean they
didn't know i was doing it of course but
but if they'd found out you know the
couple of occasions
you know where they found out i'd been
drinking or whatever they were not
totally shocked they were pretty
easygoing about that kind of thing so
and were you friends with glenn around
this time
yeah glenn was glenn uh we met at a
college radio station and uh
so probably you know that's that's
that's glenn and phil who i'm very close
to phil who was the guy in the window
who drank the coffee phil drew yeah yeah
that's hilarious yeah so he lost him
that you know phil giroud i'm going to
say it i'm going to tell phil i'll tell
phil you said what's up okay he's going
to think that oh i can see him so
clearly he was always laughing too he
was such a funny cutaway he was such a
funny person to cut away to because he
always kind of had a similar reaction
than you phil and glenn like they didn't
actually have any skin in the game
because they didn't even really want to
do the show that much right like that's
what was funny about it they had real
jobs but they were having fun with it
they'd come along and then it was just
kind of like silly you know
life could be a dream
[Music]
well these are gonna be quick uh really
quick short questions what tom is your
most commonly used emoji would you say
what is your go-to emoji that you find
yourself using oh
oh i like that um well lately it's been
the smiley face with the mask on sure
yeah probably
just the smiley face yeah i think yeah
most commonly yeah um if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why i think i know this but
uh my guess would be i'd probably say
skateboard skateboarding yeah that was
always the dream to be
really a great skateboarder when i was a
little kid it was hockey but i got to
sort of be a pseudo professional
skateboarder sort of like i got an
honorary uh pro model with tony hawk's
uh birdhouse skateboards but i i wasn't
really a professional skateboarder well
yeah to be able to actually do the
things that they do in a skateboard
would be something that is a dream of
mine for sure well there was a lot in in
terms of what you were doing there
seemed like a lot of overlap with uh
skateboarding like video skateboarding
culture um
yeah that's where it all came from for
sure oh really yeah yeah just there in
letterman letterman and
skate videos yeah that was sort of the
yeah and you say hockey at the time what
were there the were the ottawa senators
a team at the time or were you a
canadian would it be montreal no when i
was a kid we didn't have the senators
the senators didn't come in until 92 91
92 season so growing up uh when i was a
little kid i would love the montreal
canadiens
it was gila fleur was the you know yeah
the board and then ray borg but i also
liked i also like the new york islanders
because ottawa is pretty close to new
york you know a 45-minute drive to new
york state from
ottawa new york has 45-minute drive from
new york so from ottawa so um so new
york islanders mike bossie brian
trottier danny potvin that was the
dynasty
and then of course the edmonton oilers
were were were very well loved uh
if you could have one snack food what
would it be your go-to snack food
probably pizza what's your favorite
movie of all time if you have one well i
used to always say jaws i don't even
know if that's true anymore but i do
love that movie um yeah i i think i'll
stick with it jaws i love jaws somebody
wrote into the show because we've been
doing these midweek quarantine episodes
where we uh you might be into this where
we
have a hypothetical question we try to
we try to answer and um so somebody we
were encouraging people to write in with
their own hypotheticals and one was um
would you rather uh be in a in a
swimming pool
a murky swimming pool
with a great white shark or the same
size forest with a
grizzly bear and
you have to get through the length of
the forest and you have to get through
the length of the swimming pool i'd go
with the forest i'm more comfortable in
the forest with a grizzly bear yeah same
thing yeah yeah that's exactly i think
the the grizzly bears tend to
i mean i know sharks aren't
attacking people regularly as much as
but i think this the pool seems so much
smaller i think the odds of encountering
the the shark generally probably are
much higher than it is forest bears tend
to to leave you alone if you if if you
don't bother them so ah okay yeah but
that's that's probably be pretty hungry
in that pool just all by itself you know
probably be looking for something to eat
by that point by the time you got in
there but i also think because i think
that's how effective that movie is i
think it had such a dramatic impact on
it rewired me somehow and and uh
it was so effective i mean it really
tapped into this like you know real
primal fear i don't think i'll ever
escape
yeah for sure and then you know the
other thing is i i often throw in a
comedy there too so you know airplane
also would yeah would would maybe you
know be
be uh well you know in it for different
reasons you know and also the hardest
i've the hardest i've ever laughed in my
life okay while watching the movie it's
a tie between monty python's meaning of
life
and uh when when they come to take your
liver with the liver donors card but i'm
still using it that moment i was
12 years old i just couldn't [ __ ]
believe what i was looking at
and uh we believe it or not weekend at
bernie's i had this moment watching
weekend at bernie's i was first of all i
was watching it i was probably 17 years
old i was watching it on vhs
with my parents
in our in our living room and the scene
where you know the bot you know bernie's
dead the whole time and they're trying
to keep the party going and then now
they're in there in this in this in the
speed boat and and bernie falls out the
back but the anchor rope gets tied to
his leg and he get he keeps hitting the
water skiing pulls
ping
ping and it was just so outrageous that
i started laughing but then what
happened was i started laughing so hard
and so uncontrollably that i realized i
was annoying my parents and ruining the
movie which made it even funnier and it
became a quadruple can't stop laughing
that's very rare an inescapable loop of
laughter at the point that my parents
were like oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] yeah i can hear them they walked
upstairs and i kept laughing for a good
solid 20 minutes and we didn't even
finish the [ __ ] movie
that's really funny oh that's funny and
both of those answers make such they
really make sense i mean at bernie's
there are elements of talk about like
irreverence i mean the whole thing's
about this [ __ ] corpse
uh a dragon it's just a discord yeah
this sort of shocking gross out elements
of it i've never really seen that kind
of stuff and monty python too the gross
oh yeah the liquid and the you know the
the fat guy at the end vomiting and all
that just it was just i loved it growing
up in canada they played flying circus
the show on the cbc every night so it
was sort of like constantly being pumped
into our brains i think that's why we're
all nuts up there you know we had sctv
and
python and benny hill were playing on tv
constantly my entire life so oh wow well
that makes sense because you came of age
during the uh the kids in the hall when
the kids in the hall were becoming
popular and
them of course as well yeah they were
they were huge and i love those guys i
love those guys and bruce mcculloch uh
he directed that movie right stealing
harvard that you were in you got to work
he did yeah he did he directed that and
and also superstar which was the first
movie set i was ever on that was before
mtv i had a little part in that so oh
wow uh okay if you had to live somewhere
else tom where would it be
probably costa rica yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'd love it there it's very peaceful
there i mean it's it's the only thing is
it's a great i love going there
to take a break but it's it's very quiet
there but i love nature i love being
around you know
the monkeys you must love the monkeys i
was going to say you must love them i
love the monkeys
and the fishing is great down there
right we we we're going to talk about
fishing let's talk about fishing yeah
yeah what do you catch down there i i
imagine they have bass they have large
enough bass everywhere kind of right in
costa rica it's it's ocean fishing so
it's mo and i don't do a lot of fishing
down there but you catch red snapper and
small mahi mahi and tuna and things like
that but but most of my fishing
experience has grown up in lakes in
canada kind of like very similar to
where you are and
so it was a lot of
a lot of largemouth bass and a lot of uh
northern pike yeah yeah yep yep musk
lunge and lots of uh leopard frogs and
both oh yes oh yes i like catching frogs
when i was a kid i said let's see i love
watching your instagram because it's it
i see so many things that it just
reminds me of like what i do you know
like you always have cool frogs and
fish and you're fishing a lot on there
and it's a very similar kind of uh
thing to where my parents live in quebec
so oh that's cool yeah if you could have
dinner with three people dead or alive
whom you you've never met who would they
be
well um i'm gonna pick three dead people
because i
you know yeah why not probably the live
people i might get a still get a chance
to actually do it yeah you don't want to
waste your i don't want to waste one on
on a live person
i would say uh
johnny carson yes yeah um do you do it
johnny carson impression that is wild
stuff oh that's pretty cool that's good
it was uh
it was uh it was cold outside in uh los
angeles today justin
it was so cold i saw a pigeon running
into kenny rogers roasters to surrender
yes that is
thank you ed that is some wild stuff
that is that is wild
that's really good
you know you have
you have my one impression well your
cadence your natural cadence is not
dissimilar
to his i i think i've watched a lot of
johnny
over the years read everything about him
i find him very interesting yeah
there's great books about him and this
he had such an interesting life and in
some ways he's a little bit of a
cautionary tale i think about you know
as much as i loved him he
he was really so devoted to his work
that he didn't necessarily have the
family the happiest life yeah
in the end yeah yeah
because what you wish for you kind of
got to learn to like make sure you kind
of like divide
you know compartmentalize things in your
life so you're not so
driven that it's just about the show or
whatever just about the career
but i loved him and i loved his comedy i
think he's the greatest was there a time
in your lifetime where that that was
true that you felt that way that you're
looking back like i was too consumed
yeah i think so yeah i think when i was
in my you know 20s and 30s for a bit
more so i've really yeah in the last 10
years i think i've become a lot well i i
was i sort of i've been thinking about
this i'm thinking like i was very
stressed about the future
when i was young because i was like oh
my god if this doesn't work out what am
i going to do with my life but now i'm
48 years old and there's just so much
less of my life to ruin right
so right that's true
you know it's like what if i screw this
up well it's sort of over anyway so yeah
it doesn't really matter that much
that's true it's kind of comforting yeah
if things went to [ __ ] when i was 30
though man you know and yeah
yeah i put a lot of pressure on myself
that's funny i wonder if that's similar
yeah i think as we get older things just
you just get more relaxed and you start
to roll with the punches more and more
and more and i you know i feel better
about things now than i ever have so
johnny carson two others right
yeah uh
johnny carson um
jesus
i want to get a woman in there because
you know you want to have to sit dinner
with three dudes so you know
johnny carson jesus and um
marilyn monroe yeah fascinating yeah
jesus and johnny and i all competing for
her attention she ends up with jesus at
the end of the meal
ironically
yeah
uh bye johnny bye tom let's go jesus
girls love nice guys
um if
if if you could uh classic jesus
uh if you could be one age for the rest
of your life physically what would you
pick physically or mentally and
emotionally too no no you have your own
the mental capacity you have now but in
a whatever body
oh okay
i'd i'd probably say
22 or something like that mm-hmm yeah
that was a good one uh who's your
favorite muppet oh the muppet who played
the sax oh yeah god i was just looking
him up uh yeah he was great he never
said anything he just went right at the
end yeah like zoot his name the cool
shades and the hat yes what the [ __ ] was
his name now you know but let me give
you another answer because i don't know
if that's good i think it is i might be
the sweetest chef the swedish chef ah i
love the swedish chef yeah
[Music]
gibberish i love it i couldn't believe i
think that was actually the one that
really i love yeah me too me too um
uh okay if you could be reincarnated as
a non-human animal what would you pick
an elephant
why i just think they're highly
intelligent
you know i don't know everything about
elephants but i know they have a lot of
uh
family structure
yeah they have a lot of social structure
between them so it just seems like it
would be not as boring as being say like
you know
i don't know like a turtle or yeah
yes
you uh yeah and don't do they have they
have really good memories is that true a
packager that's the
i think they do and i you know there's
these these things i've watched online
that are just incredible about like
there was one
story i i think it was in south africa
but it was somewhere in africa but uh
the the elephants were
endangered and a farmer
kept them in a sanctuary and saved them
from these poachers
and he's he then he kept these elephants
there for many years
and then when the threat of the poachers
was gone
these elephants left
20 years later or something like that
i'm not getting the dates right but this
this gentleman
died okay
and the elephants
somehow knew it
wow sensed it
and they came back no and they had a
sort of a ritualistic type of it's on
the youtube there's a whole thing about
a mic and they came back and they did a
ritualistic kind of like a serum you
know morning
foreign for his wife and they were there
for many many days mourning this man's
death and then so i found that kind of a
beautiful thing wow yeah i'm very
interested in animals there's also
another incredibly interesting animal is
a sperm whale
they're starting to do a lot of research
about sperm whales and they've
discovered that the sperm whale has more
complex language than human language oh
my god yeah i have a friend who's a
nature photographer who goes to
he goes to sri lanka and and films them
uh and he has to use the snorkel you
can't use scuba equipment because the
exactly because they're afraid of the
scuba tanks yeah they're just yeah i
love that i find that fascinating uh i
don't know how to make a pivot from this
uh which golden girl do you most
identify with
dorothy
rose or sophia
b arthur it was the b arthur character
that's dorothy you're a dorothy yeah b
arthur for sure so is christian my
brother's a dorothy um would you rather
be called unattractive or unfunny
unattractive yeah uh which do you prefer
dogs or cats
dogs do you have you don't have pets now
i had cats growing up i love cats but
i've i had i had two huskies for 15
years they just passed away about three
years ago and so i haven't gotten new
dogs but i
and i love cats too but i've sort of
become slightly allergic to cats for
some reason that's developed but also
just like dogs are just kind of like
you know like cats are cool but it's
they don't really care you know they're
just kind of they're sitting there but
the dogs i like the dogs you know they
come to you and they make you feel like
they actually care about you and stuff
especially now i mean especially if i
were you know now that we're
by ourselves in this time and we're
uh
we were like kind of cooped up it'd be
nice to have a dog somebody was showing
you a little affection yeah i've
actually been thinking about it because
i don't know how long this is going to
last and uh you know like like the the
the reason i didn't get a new dog is
because i'm touring pretty much
constantly so i just sort of wasn't
really didn't really make it anymore but
uh but if
yeah i definitely think i could use a
little fluffy fella around here right
now i wonder if i could borrow a dog for
a few months anything can you do that
wonder someone lenny yeah you know
i think you can foster dogs yeah you can
take them just for four months and then
like have literally no attachment would
form and then after four months just
okay thanks good knowing and then just
give it back you know yes would be
impossible for me the sec
that's the problem anytime i've ever
even come close to a
having a dog
in my possession for more than a minute
and then i almost you know adopt it
right away so that's how i got my two
other dogs
so yeah you have too big a heart um
would you rather be able to eat meatloaf
the food for the rest of your life or
listen to meatloaf the singer
me love the food yeah
okay um and do you ever think about how
you want to be remembered tom uh what
you want people to think of you and
i i guess legacy what you want your
legacy to be ah well i guess like you
said earlier it'd be nice if people said
that he was a funny guy i'd like that
yeah
yeah yeah so you never had uh
so your ambitions have changed i mean
it's is that safe to say you know i was
always powered and driven by fear in in
my life i was always fear feared the
idea of having to get a real job okay
yeah so it was always just this scary
idea that like oh my gosh if this comedy
thing doesn't work out if these videos
don't catch on i'm gonna have to go like
to school and like sit at a desk and
probably yeah what would you do do you
think i probably would have been like a
telemarketer or something you know or
working a dairy queen making peanut
buster parfaits which i've done and i'm
very good at by the way yeah i yeah i
used to work at carvel i was pretty damn
good myself i made the best peanut
buster parfaits at the beacon hill mall
because i put like extra
fudge at the bottom i put like outside
of the standard amount of fudge i'd put
in especially when my friends came
that's just that dairy queen yeah yeah
did you guys have uh is that when they
had the helmets the baseball helmets
maybe that was only in the u.s no they
had that they had that in canada they
did yeah they did actually yeah i love
that yeah i was a big blue jays fan for
some reason i guess it was around the
time they were doing well and yeah i
loved like john yeah
roberto alomar was on that team roberto
alamar that's right and john olrude yeah
yeah they had a really good team um
well i
[ __ ] tom i i it's just been so fun i'm
love talking to you absolutely thanks
man okay and say hi to christian for me
and thanks so much man we'll do i'll
talk to you later thanks buddy i'll talk
to you soon okay bye justin bye
bye
so well that happened
hey well that happened
he is so i mean you can hear it it's
unmistakable i wonder if people in
non-english-speaking countries
can hear the difference between a
canadian accent and an american accent i
would bet they could like an accident
like that his accent is so thick that it
it almost sounds like he's doing a
canadian accent i know yeah he sounds
like one of those guys on uh he sounds
like he's doing a really good canadian
accent yeah
well i suppose
uh not so great canadian well that's not
bad
there's something surreal about talking
to him because i feel like i knew him so
well or i i had such a clear idea of him
as a kid do you know what i mean like oh
it was surreal meeting him yeah last
year it was i think the stuff he did on
a show 20 years ago
was more of a character than i ever
thought it was right but i think that
speaks to what is that gift he does but
i think that speaks to what a gifted
performer he is because at the time uh
he was so committed to that to his
material and it was
his performance was just so
real seeming that i naturally just
assumed that this was this guy's
personality and he was this
fear like skinny canadian guy fearless
guy who could walk up to anybody
and say anything
when in reality he was uh
a different kind of guy and this was a
performance that he was
pushing out there yeah you you know you
can really see it when he did the
interviews like the talk show style
segments on his show remember that when
he would like
he kind of took a power position over um
glenn glenn was his foil glenn was like
the straight man to his uh he was his ed
mcmahon
but glenn was like a great straight man
because he was like
he was very uh he was like uh
margaret dumont with the marx brothers
he was like oh come on he was like the
perfect straight guy
like you're saying the persona that he
had was very different than
let's say
the talk show he does or he did with
larry king yeah
i was almost like on guard when i did
that show i remember kind of having my
guard up a little bit and get ready to
comedically like jab with one another
and then when he was just very connected
and at a certain point i was watching
the interview and i thought is he just
doing is this like performance our andy
kaufman [ __ ] where he's just trying to
do
like a totally great larry king
impression because we're i think that's
just who he is i think so too we still
have this image of him right in our
heads from like the punk rock tom green
who's like doing [ __ ] with people and
he's so good at [ __ ] with people yeah
that in like the poo on the microphone
bit where he stares where he stares at
their eyes yeah he's really committed
he's so good at that but i think he's an
amazing actor like he's convinced me
that this is exactly who he is yeah
so you think he might still you think he
maybe was doing a bit of a larry king
bit
and i don't think that i thought that at
the time but now i think that his re his
normal personality is just more
laid-back yeah i think thoughtful and
introspective and the tom green show tom
green
was more of a performance yeah like for
example he's also a kid he's also his
funniest but for yeah we were like we
said we were very different but he
claims that that was a performance well
it's you know what it's like when he was
asking me about fishing on his show and
he was like oh i heard you like to fish
you like to catch the fish that's johnny
carson the more you do that the more it
sounds like johnny carson well maybe
he's more influenced by johnny carson or
it's a terrible impression but he would
say things like that do you catch that
remember we had that back and forth not
on this show but on his when he goes you
like to catch the um
the bass the largemouth bass the perch
yeah yeah and so i started going like oh
yeah yeah i like the uh the trout a
rainbow maybe a maybe a brook trout
what do you call that you're um
like mimicry oh maybe that's it
maybe that's it or it was just like oh
he's doing a bit now and and this whole
fishing thing is a weird bit where he's
like but then afterwards after the show
we wanted to talk about fishing yeah and
he was like hey we should go fishing
sometimes so we like fishing it's also
david letterman uh yes it's very late
letterman was influenced by johnny
carson they they have a similar kind of
cadence
yeah at the end i was very happy that he
said this that he was a dorothy mm-hmm
golden girls yeah see i wouldn't have
thought that tom green from our youth
was adorable no the tom green from our
youth would have been uh
sophia maybe
i think a black
maybe a yeah
i guess so uh blanche i'm trying to
picture blanche pulling pranks but i
think blanche is too young
sexual no no she's a good time she's
she's like fun
yeah yeah not i wouldn't but like but
still proper i mean she's still a
southern lady
that's true you know so i don't think
she would be putting poo poo on the end
of a microphone maybe more sophia then
yeah
yeah i guess so
sorry to
well he in real life he's a dorothy
uh-huh and you said oh my brother's a
dorothy and under his breath he's goes
yeah but i know that he didn't really
internalize that i was a dorothy and he
didn't agree with you but i was really
hoping
that he did and i convinced myself that
he agreed that i'm adorable like you
know so well that made my teenage dreams
come true uh well you know he listens to
the show it sounded like he actually
does listen really yeah and mark we
should mention that margaret who now
fans of the show will know
from last week's episode uh
maggie uh is a huge i didn't know this
until after we finished the interview i
did not either she's a massive tom green
fan all right i got off the phone with
tom and she was like she had been she
was hiding in the next room yeah you
know listening
at the house here we were doing the
podcast and afterwards she was like a
giddy little i think i took a video of
her and sent it to tom just to be like
i i wanted him to know that what a huge
fan i thought it was really cool i like
that she likes him yeah i mean she has
good taste yeah but she was really we've
interviewed how many people since i've
known her i mean like she hasn't been
this excited never has that reaction and
like she was like a giddy
kid she was like a teenager she was like
made me like her more yeah
so i hope tom's listening to this one
uh let's read a letter okay okay okay oh
yeah reading a letter
reading yeah it is i mean there's a lot
of johnny carson and letterman yes
that's right that's right it's weird
weird wild stuff i'm gonna read it from
this is from aaron k
you like that name
ed aaron k please
miscellaneous comments i can't
miscellaneous comments compliments
suggestions
and happy would you rather great hello
justin and christian uh i'm sure you've
already gotten a million emails about
this but i hate caps people singing me
happy birthday especially strangers it's
so awkward and embarrassing i think you
guys are the weirdos that you actually
like it yeah i think you know i bet
she's right i bet a lot of people hate
that i don't want to right or wrong it's
just an opinion not right and i respect
your opinion but you're wrong yeah it's
fun it's fun but i but when they're
singing to you i i feel her on that when
you're getting sung to you right yeah it
can be embarrassing the whole restaurant
yeah i don't like it back to the letter
i'm from pennsylvania so if you think
you can do a pa dutch accent i'd love to
hear it oh god and lavish so what do you
want me to try i bet it's gonna sound a
lot like your canadian accent um i'm
trying to think you're thinking amish
you know you're thinking of kingpin i'm
also thinking of pittsburgh as a very
different affair
who had that
that strong baltimore accent accent uh
who was that that we were watching on oh
yeah someone recently oh my god it was a
really thick oh it was a cop on that
unsolved mystery yeah sorry
by the way not an ad but unsolved
mysteries that's right
on netflix it's amazing so good okay i
can't do i'm not going to try aaron but
um i would like to hear what it sounds
like i love accents anyways i love your
podcast and your grandmother was the
coolest guest
justin i think it's cool how you
interact differently with each guest you
do a great job you're really bringing
out each guest personality i'm not sure
if that's an interview strategy or who
you are as a person but it works really
well that's such a nice compliment
interview strategy
does it make me sound phony a little bit
no i think it's who you are as a person
phony
and christian is amazing at analyzing
the interview this is so nice he could
be a literary critic or a sociologist oh
sorry a sociolinguist or something
sociolinguist that's cool i don't know
that was a thing
but you could be that thanks i feel a
little bit guilty that i haven't really
been thriving during quarantine yeah i
don't feel guilty
with all the free time oh i see with all
the free time i'm finally getting the
time to do things i never had the time
to do in the past i'm learning a new
language learning how to roller skate
completing projects i started long ago
and practicing photography oh she sounds
like she's doing a lot yeah i know she
feels guilty that she's enjoying it oh
oh oh i feel that yeah i know not
everyone has the same privilege that i
do i see but with everything coming to a
halt all of a sudden i'm realizing that
the pace i was living before was way too
fast
and making me unhappy i feel lucky to be
able to slow down and really enjoy life
i also have a suggestion for one of your
lightning round questions great all of
your guests seem to either be comedians
or at least highly value their sense of
humor and don't care how they look so in
the question about being unfunny or ugly
everyone answers the same
she's not i just i disagree oh really
yeah i think we've had a pretty good mix
of people saying um oh really i think
she's right most of them say oh
definitely i'd rather be under thought
of his own didn't david harbor say uh
yeah i wouldn't want people to think
about attractive and dax shepard yeah
i did david maybe said that it's very
honest whoever does say i i like when
people say that yeah because it uh
it reveals something it's honesty yeah
yeah and even that not that the other
people are not aren't being honest but
i like when people admit to vanity yeah
maybe that that's well said um
and that says a lot about somebody you
can admit to that so anyway maybe we'll
keep it for now right here but um i was
with you for a second but that was a
good argument because you're a
sociolinguist
uh what if you ask if they so she has a
suggestion what if you ask if they would
rather be seen as ugly or unintelligent
or do all three
ah that's good if you had to pick one
would you rather be seen as unfunny ugly
or unintelligent
i think there'd be i think unintelligent
and unfunny are too connected they're
too similar
so i think it would be an unfa i don't
think those are three equal
things
so i think the um
you know it's like kanye west running
for president he's gonna take votes from
joe biden yeah i see you know what i
mean but he's not a true independent
third-party candidate that's true which
i think if the question if we're going
to add a third thing it should be a
third very different thing
but who would that be though but i think
that be associated with a sense of humor
with intelligence a lot like very i
associate them a lot i think people who
would pick either of those do as well um
if they were we'll take it under advice
yeah okay all right but don't just let
that discourage you from writing no even
though he just shot down here too no
let's think about it all right all right
that's a good thing to think about yeah
yeah um on the topic of would you
rathers i don't remember hearing any
positive would you rathers on the show
so here are a few i came up with
positive would you rather's very
appropriate for tom greenweek yes yeah
because there's nothing mean about him
by the way that's true and
and you guys talk about that a bit in
the conversation yeah you could argue
that maybe th
i mean was his comedy meaner back in the
day i think he pushed the envelope but
he talked about the difference between
um
americans and canadians and how in
canada he would do this these bits yeah
and people would enjoy it more and kind
of revel in this
the
surreality of it yeah and um whereas in
in new york he almost you know he got
attacked that when he first did that
that pizza bit you guys
so yeah but he's like right away i
realize that's that's a pretty big
difference that canadians kind of enjoy
well again another reason why i love
canadians because i feel like they would
have more fun with the prank elements
and poking fun at themselves which is
why and i i like to think that i think
more like that which is maybe why when i
watched the tom green show i never found
it mean i don't think it was i never
found out i don't think it was yeah
huh um okay back to aaron's letter uh
positive would you rather this is i'm
excited would you rather be able to eat
whatever you want and as much as you
want and stay in perfect health or
always get a perfect night of sleep with
really cool dreams oh that's a good one
um eat whatever i want me too but i i i
think part of it is because you value
food more than i value delicious food
more than crazy dreams number one and
number two but i
go ahead sorry i have a counter argument
to that
what if you your really cool dreams
involved delicious foods
come on
also think about i mean you could do a
lot of things in really cool dreams
yeah
i guess so i mean
it just depends what you're lacking in
your life i guess right okay
what are you saying don't read too much
yes and what am i lacking um
but also i i
i like the challenge of
getting a good night's sleep i like the
challenge
i like the ritual of
you know taking melatonin sometimes and
making sure i have eight hours oh what
by the way add a challenge whereas it
would be nice to just shovel whatever i
wanted in my body that's true and not
only not gain weight but be in perfect
health that's true like that'd be cool
i wouldn't be fat on the outside or fat
on the inside do we look like ripped do
we look like a like no no but no you're
just like
healthy yeah that would be that'd be
cool that'd be great think about it
think about all the guilt you feel man
when you're stoned and you have an ice
cream cone it's hard for you to enjoy it
oh by the way shout out to van lewin oh
and luan i love i
love you they sent this is not an ad
even they just sent us all this ice
cream
and uh if you're in the neighborhood of
a van lewin store store
honeycomb or as a canadian would say
honeycomb
delicious delicious thank you ben lemon
it's so [ __ ] good vegan great vegan
options with made without milk delicious
you wouldn't know the difference okay so
uh
eating one thing is there another one
yes would you rather be a creative
genius or a scientific genius oh
uh you know
i
selfishly i'd rather be a creative
genius but i would pick scientific
genius
because it's better for the better for
the world yeah potentially oh that's
very that's very noble of you it's also
you're a genius there's a lot of
creative geniuses out there that have
lived and and what does that mean i mean
it's all very subjective even if you're
a creative genius some people might be
like yeah but i [ __ ] hate him still
whereas if you're a scientific genius
like the things you could do i mean the
things you could do just now i mean you
could also you could be a creative
genius like mozart and be an [ __ ]
yeah that's true that's true
yeah or
yeah a lot of people out of people i
don't want to say any of them i don't
want to say current ones because you get
trouble you get the point you
everyone knows who the creative [ __ ]
are yeah okay the genius [ __ ]
yeah but i'm sure they're scientific
genius [ __ ] too definitely think
about i mean i don't want to think
anyone who's that good at something
genius i don't think they're i think
most geniuses are probably [ __ ] you
think do you think the genius community
has the highest percentage of [ __ ]
as than any other community i'm sure
well maybe the dictator community
hmm interesting i've met kind geniuses
phil hoffman is it was a genius
so
what would you guess
has a higher percentage of [ __ ]
which group okay a pta uh-huh or mensa
i would say they're more [ __ ] than
mensa i would guess that too yeah yeah
all right
uh let's see did you just make your
point
uh would you rather be fluent in all
human languages oh cool
or be able to speak to and understand
animals these are great aaron uh wow uh
i would love um and humans i'd rather be
fluent but imagine being able to speak
to and this is a tough one
i i mine's easy yours is human language
no animals yeah surprisingly because i'm
more of a human person than an animal
person yeah but i think
as cool as it would be to be able to go
to any country it'd be good anybody yeah
you'd first of all you'd have to get
there
so it requires more legwork whereas
with animals you just step outside and
you talk to a whole bunch of different
types of animals different species yeah
but yeah yeah but let me counter
argument what if that what if animals
are just everything you're hearing from
them and you can't turn it off it's like
i want food oh that'd be nice
that's the thing so they're not they
have no decorum
all they're looking for is like they're
like or like the frogs you meet a frog
and it's in the springtime all right the
question is the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you what a [ __ ] no you're not species so
if the question is dude if the question
is you have to understand them
all the time yeah then i would pick the
human one but if you can turn it on and
off yeah
also
i bet most of them there are a lot of
people who can speak a lot of human
languages no one can speak animal
languages yeah but animals are you would
be the only that would be cool one and
you would be able to dr form speaking of
being a scientific genius you would be
able to inform
science
so much if you could understand animals
you know the first thing you do if you
understand animals
immediately what is it uh immediately
lifestyle change
you become doctor doolittle no you
become a vegan
oh of course right away unless the
animals are total [ __ ] for that if
they're like menstrual level [ __ ]
even so even if they were [ __ ] it
would freak you out too much to eat
something that you could come speak with
even to eat its eggs to be like i pushed
out another one for you you [ __ ] you
know what you'd have to do though in
that case you would just have to avoid
being around cows because i think you're
basically chickens and think about it
yeah the what are the animals you see
squirrels all right i'm a little shocked
birds
you don't want to eat any of that that's
true that's true you don't have cows
walking through your backyard that's
right after you're right i'd have to
avoid you you have to avoid pigs cows
fish chickens i couldn't be around a
lobster tank fish yeah by the way all
those lobsters were like
[Music]
i don't want to get it
uh that'd be freaky it'd be freaky to
talk to animals be weird i'm picturing
now cows
oh just chilling out here is that the
last one oh okay sorry um
yeah thanks for making the podcast oh
thanks for your letter what a great
great
man i'm
i was ready for like what would you
rather have like a knife up uranus or
a knife in your eyeball
neither yeah uh but i guess i'd rather
have one in my eyeball
really oh definitely have it in the anus
well let's see really it would probably
hurt more in your anus
says who
like cutting oh yeah that's nothing
here's
uranus is a hole your eyeball is not a
hole how about this that's a crucial
difference
yeah you don't have to puncture an
[ __ ] you just have to put a knife up
it but it would cut your probably
at least you could probably get your
butthole fixed well i'm glad i brought
it up oh man we got to cut this part out
what a night we ended aaron had such a
nice thoughtful i know um
well thanks aaron and thanks aaron and
thank you to tom it's being a great
thing the legend yeah tom green uh yeah
we both are really
flattered
if you're listening to the show because
even if you're not we're very grateful
that you did the show yeah and i'm you
know i'd really like to hang out with
tom and go fishing with him up in
toronto that'd be cool um we've talked
about it uh i'd like to do that the
lakes north of toronto are supposed to
be beautiful
anyway if you live up there uh
well done and thanks for listening and
thanks even if you don't live in canada
thanks for listening
uh and thanks to yeah
tom yeah and we'll see you guys next
life could week a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's a co-hosted and produced by
you
christian long as well as her megan
monaco as senior producer is michelle
miesh lanzi
uh audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louis
enernon lopez for wondering a we'll see
you next week
be heard by you next week oh
sorry
[Music]
i never knew frankie was a pedophile
why do you think why did you think he
got he was burned i thought he was just
accidentally burned and then why is why
is he such a monster to kids in their
dreams because he because that's a
horrible way to die and he probably
resents the school for being then he'd
take it out on like the school
administrators or like that
you would only haunt like three people
who are in charge of like school
regulations no but you say the same
thing about any haunting like why does
so so haunt this house because she died
there she was murdered there why did she
take it out of the guests of the house
well because she was died there i don't
think anyone there there aren't ghosts
that are on the level of freddie krueger
that like
target
ghosts don't like try to kill people in
like hotels
they're like
like they don't haunt them they they
like go
they're like
they travel around in their vicinity but
they're not like
they're not like really an expert
well
have you ever heard ghost stories where
it was like somebody was well actually i
have heard them where they're like
getting scratched
yeah all right you don't have a point i
don't have an answer
but freddy krueger goes after these kids
because he's them
he kills them i love haunting that's
funny it is high level hunting it's he
kills them he does yeah and isn't would
that be haunting in their dreams i guess
so
he's a ghost
they still don't really get how he's how
he does it
he makes them like like in the dream
there's a really stupid idea for a movie
no it's not it's a cool idea yeah
it doesn't it's not logical i know but
he's there is superman
that's logical that was someone for
another planet could i guess someone
it's true how does freddy krueger get
into a dream it doesn't make sense
it's like it's like counter to physics
he's a ghost i mean
yeah
well i guess you're not supposed to
think too much about it
you